I've been doing work recently in myths
and misconceptions related to cyber
security and I thought I would discuss
one of the biggest myths that we don't
really understand what cyber security
is if we look
at uh characteristics of a common field
and let's think of something like
chemistry or medicine or
psychology these fields have a history
associated with them there is an
accepted body of knowledge that everyone
practicing in the field is generally
aware of uh some generally accepted
references books standards other things
and common terminology that they use now
when those aren't fully developed we end
up having myths and misconceptions and
folklore that people fill in to explain
what they're using and uh how they're
doing things and again to sort of go
back and look at uh chemistry for
instance very early on the Alchemists
who were the early chemists talked about
finding a philosopher stone or other
kinds of things that now we view as as
uh well I won't say nonsense but
certainly uninformed and in medicine the
going back to the ancient Greeks talking
about the four bodily humors and how
they had to be in balance and that was
the cause of disease so so once science
advances Beyond a certain point we are
able to dispel these myths but some of
them tend to hang around for a
while um I'm going to say cyber
security is not a new
field um it is not the same as Computing
uh cyber security involves other things
but we have a history that goes back
into the mid 1960s which is not that
long ago when you compare it to other
more established disciplines but one of
the very first items describing cyber
security issues although not by that
name uh was the wear report cheered by
Willis wear uh project multic that was
started a couple years after that to
explore operating system architecture
and security issues uh the Anderson
report by Jim Anderson that was a follow
on to the wear report and then um an
early series
defining secure Computing system systems
the rainbow series that included what
was known as the orange book in the US
The Trusted computer systems evaluation
criteria that came out in 83 and
thereafter similar kinds of standards
were issued in other countries uh but
these are all the early precursors of
the field that Define that we really did
have a history and an
organization uh not only that we have
developed over time a number of standard
common bodies of knowledge we also have
organizations government organizations
and others setting standards of behavior
and standards of compliance in the US
nist created the cyber security
framework and that's been widely adopted
around the world by a number of
countries as a set of controls and
standards for how to protect systems we
have international organizations like
isaka and ISC squared uh the British
standards organiz ation the iso all have
set various standards relating to cyber
security practice so the field is
becoming more defined we also have a
number of standard references and
textbooks in the area uh Matt Bishop's
very definitive work on computer
security the textbooks Fleer bivan uh
Anderson's wonderful security
engineering book uh that he wrote as a
professor at Cambridge William Stallings
book
so we have standard textbooks and these
are used not only for teaching but as
reference items we also have common
terms of art that are peculiar to cyber
security for instance when we talk about
a virus we're not talking about the
biological virus we are talking about
something that uh alters and embeds
itself in computer software on our
computers Ransom is a term of art that
does not get used anywhere other than in
cyber
security uh when we talk about return
oriented programming or R that's another
term that has become unique to cyber
security and we have other terms like
side Channel and and others that are
there so if we look at
this set of characteristics this really
matches what I said about defining a
field cyber security as a field is
becoming more defined over its 60 or so
years of existence and I'll note here
that it is much more than just Computing
which is why I said it's not really a
subset of computing because it also
involves issues of psychology economics
law um communication Theory and other
kinds of issues that are outside the
realm of traditional Computing the word
cloud I have here actually is related to
that we look at these and we see these
as things that are related to cyber
security but these terms are all more
oriented towards relationships of people
and organizations well given all of that
context we can say Okay cyber security
is a field good um why do we have such
problems with it and I'll say it's
because of one myth that we've sort of
glossed over with all of this in the
idea that we have a clear definition of
cyber security
and I'll show you why that really isn't
true
um and I'll do that sort of walking
through some some analysis of potential
definition really part of it gets to the
root of what is security we use the term
Security in a lot of ways we talk about
National Security we talk about personal
security data security uh and others if
we're a company and somebody does
something wrong we tell them to call
security uh but what does it really mean
in the 60s when some of the experts were
doing the initial work and they were
analyzing computer
security they realized that it's an
unattainable goal and I'll show you that
in a moment so they then started talking
about trusted systems rather than secure
systems the idea of building computers
that we could trust to execute uh
according to of
policy well that also turned out to be
extraordinarily difficult
and actually unreachable and so they
switched terms to the idea of
trustworthy
systems that lasted for a while um
became also difficult to justify and the
terminology changed to the idea of
resilience systems so in the early part
of this Century uh many of the people
working in the film in the field started
talking about
uh computer system
resiliency of late we've now moved away
even from that because that also seems
to be a somewhat vague term and we talk
about risk risk factors risk reduction
risk
abatement is this where we'll end up uh
as a definition area not sure but I will
say that without a clear definition of
cyber security or some one of these
these terms we can't build appropriate
metrics and without metrics it's very
difficult to determine if some new
development advancement or
configuration is both an improvement and
worth the
investment metrics are critically
important for defining any scientific or
engineering field and are very important
for making
progress It's also the question here
about whatever definition we have how is
it related to safety and to privacy both
are Concepts that repeatedly appear
whenever we talk about
security so where we are now is
basically with folk wisdom old Concepts
and sort of vague
Notions let me give you an example here
if we start with an intuitive definition
that a system is secure if it's
protected against all forms of threat
that would seem to be what most people
would nod their heads at and say yes
that's a good definition not being away
um
then where does that take us well if we
start examining that and we start
thinking can we achieve
it um can we protect against random
hackers oh yeah I think most trained
cybercity professionals with available
tools and Technologies can keep the
random individuals out of their systems
almost all the
time malware things like computer
viruses and
ransomware um probably if you have
people who are focused and uh paying
close attention to what's going
on how about nation state hackers this
would be in the area of Espionage or
conflict and they're probably not the
the countries that are practicing cyber
warfare or cyber
Espionage have a lot of resources and
many talented people and have shown time
and again that they're able to penetrate
even good
resources so there there's an example
where our security perhaps isn't quite
so good but it's even worse than that
can we protect our systems against the
UFO
Invasion um no now um here's a threat
picture a threat model that we don't
understand it hasn't occurred before
that that we know of and therefore we
don't know what we need to protect
against what defenses what indicators
and warnings and so we're effectively
not protected at all against something
like this we could send in Jeff gold
Blum right if we had Jeff gold Blum with
a properly configured Macintosh yes if
we plant a virus into that Mother Ship
yeah but that's exactly it how about an
Extinction event meteor
impact yeah there's no way that your IT
staff is going to protect against that
and and that wouldn't be the first
priority in any event uh um If This Were
to occur effectively all of our
Computing resources would be disabled
and destroyed although we wouldn't
necessarily have a population who wanted
to use them but you're thinking how
about if we set up some Mars colonies
and we send them backup tapes of all our
data and our cat
videos will that preserve them and well
that's not a bad idea for a number of
reasons but eventually the heat death of
the sun when it expands into a red giant
uh will consume all of the inner planets
including Mars and that's the end of
that strategy but if you're again sort
of thinking ahead here you sort of say
well we're not confined to the solar
system best projections now is that
there will be a heat death of the
universe eventually and all Computing
will come to an end and in that regard
we've also lost the security battle what
this illustrates is a couple things
first of all that it's not a helpful
definition because we can never actually
achieve it and second it also shows that
that security generally is an economics
issue more than an engineering task or
at least as part of an engineering task
because engineering requires an
investment and we can build in
safeguards of increasing complexity and
and uh difficulty of penetration given a
threat model we can never reach 100% And
that the increase in what we have to
spend may not be worth what we're
protecting so as a definition of cyber
security what I just showed you doesn't
really work very
well let's try a different approach and
look at system design rather than
protecting an existing system can we do
something
better well research in the uh 1970s
1980s when some of this was originally
done looked at the idea of system State
and any of you have looked at Computing
a little more formally know the idea of
state that's the value that's in memory
and registers on a system and if we
start off by saying we're going to
define a set of States as okay or secure
and we can do that according to a formal
model and I mentioned a couple security
models here Bella laula or BBA you don't
need to you don't need to worry about
those unless you've studied them but the
idea is that we can have a policy that
says what a safe state
is as the system executes as the
computer runs through its instructions
it changes state it goes from one state
to another and as long as valid
operations result in the system still
being in one of those allowed States
it's still
secure but that implies and in truth
there are bad States
or unsafe or unsecure States and those
are ones we don't want to occur we don't
want to enter one of those bad States
and we especially don't want remain in
there so we enter a bad State and stay
an operation in that bad state or cease
operation entirely so the notion of
allowed States is a match to the concept
of system specification in software
engineering the execution of a state
that's not in a specification is a fault
that can result in a failure a failure
in a protected system is a security
failure and I note that security was a
driver in the development of software
engineering but we're not limited to
just non-secure and secure States we
also have undefined States because in a
Computing system with any appreciable
amount of memory not to mention multiple
uh uh processors that are involved we're
going to have so many states we can't
Define all of them and some of them are
undefined those are not part of the
specification if program execution
enters one of those undefined States
that's an error and it may or may not be
a fault it could possibly lead to uh
abnormal behavior or a security problem
some of those undefined States we may
enter and they'll lead back to an okay
state but they're undefined so we don't
know well this is what program State
space probably really looks like is we
have a small number of specified secure
States and a larger set of uh specified
unsafe unsecure States but a huge
Universe of States we have no idea what
is going on in those
systems so this is what it would look
like if we had
specifications but the problem is that
very few bits of software reuse have
been formally
specified the programs that we download
or that wey buy from major
vendors generally are not specified
they're built according to an informal
ad hoc specification and very often
they're modified on the fly without any
kind of careful design and consideration
for what the system should be so one of
my favorite quotes a program that's not
been specified cannot be incorrect it
can only be
surprising this is the current state of
cyber
security really if we're going to be
accurate most of the behaviors that we
say are security problems are not really
a failure of design or a failure of
building they're a surprise because the
software is behaving in a way that we
didn't anticipate it's a
surprise it's not a good surprise in
many cases but it shouldn't be a
surprise because we haven't built the
software carefully to begin
with so
that's in summary a little bit of where
we are now with the whole idea of cyber
security we have
surprises we don't know how to build
systems
correctly in the general case and we
don't invest enough to build them
correctly and we don't have the
Personnel necessary to build them
correctly so we're still searching for
that alcher The Alchemist Stone to try
to buy and add on to our systems or
trying to apply leeches to get the
systems to behave appropriately uh but
that isn't really the the underlying
solution we have to go back to First
principles and do a better job on design
if we do that if we can come up with
that better definition of design it will
help us in future generation of systems
of architecture of software um it will
enhance our communication across
disciplines support development of
better
tools and of course metrics which will
allow us to decide appropriate
investment so all of this requires that
we really understand what we're doing
and get away from the myths uh and the
misconceptions and the folklore that
we've been using up to this point and
with that I'll I'll state this has been
part of an ongoing project uh where I've
worked with some others to try to
document some of these myths and
misconceptions that we've been applying
uh over the years and cyber security in
particular here's information where you
can find out more it made me think
actually the idea of going back to First
principles I mean there are so it's so
complex isn't it we've got Hardware
we've got operating systems we've got
user experience we've got software
sitting on that that you know if we're
still at the stage of if the witch
floats uh she's witch if she thinks
she's not a wit you know do you see what
I'm saying how how do you return to
First principles in a system that's
already so complicated this is related
to uh the economic issue of sun cost we
have such a huge investment in
infrastructure training
software that people are loathed to
throw that out and go back to First
principles part of what those of us in
Academia and some industry are doing in
research is trying to develop better
systems um there's probably not enough
attention being paid to that area of
research uh I've certainly run into
issues where talking to people uh
they're not interested in research for
better security unless it works on Linux
or Windows on an Intel processor well
right there we've set constraints that
may not be
appropriate um if we develop something
that works
better then demonstrating that in
isolated
environments is helpful now we do have
some better secured systems that are in
use in nuclear power in avionics in
space but they're
expensive and without good metrics it's
difficult to justify using those
Solutions in the commercial Marketplace
like at Banks or or online uh vendors so
it's it's a it's a complex ecosystem
here government is getting involved now
in various venues around the world the
the EU uh great they're they're in the
UK in the US we're seeing more pressure
on building secure systems and better um
better accounting for what we do and
that may help change the
economic balance a little bit but it's
evolving and we have to keep in mind it
really the field is Young and it will
take some time before this all settles
out you mentioned there the kind of leg
legislation side of it but while we're
still in this period of effectively
running around plugging holes and um
writing spaghetti code to fix problems
that we find that we didn't anticipate
we were going to find um
there's there's always got to be that
balance between convenience you know
practicality and you know cost as well
as um kind of security hasn't it because
you know you can make even modern
computer relatively safe if you
disconnect it from everything but then
you lose the convenience right right and
again this comes down to not being able
to evaluate the trade-offs well if we
can't measure the difference in how
secure safe price private our systems
are if we connect or if we connect in a
certain way it's difficult for anyone to
make a judgment about is it worth it to
me to do so so right now we have lots of
people making that decision on a feeling
that it's a it's it's an acceptable uh
kind of risk or that uh we have to do it
this way to be able to be in business
and if they don't know what the
alternative are and they don't know how
to measure
it they can't really make a fully
informed choice and the other thing I
was thinking was can we use existing
technology to bootstrap some of these
ideas to you know use some kind of
machine Learning System to say right
okay if we started from scratch um you
might the system that's designing it
might not be able to run on it almost
like the blacksmith who makes the
sharper tool from the sharp tool is that
something that maybe maybe something you
are researching or
how do you come up with this
specification I suppose some people are
looking at that uh we actually have
developed techniques over the years and
architectures that work well it's a
matter of can we convince people to use
them the I I mentioned sunk cost as one
of the issues um probably the biggest
issue we have is
complexity that because of sun cost what
we do is add on new layers we put in new
tools uh new boundaries we move things
into virtual machines we move things
into Cloud
environments all in an attempt to
address a certain set of problems but
what they actually end up doing is add
to the
complexity and complexity is where
unanticipated unknown failures
occur uh where because we don't
understand whole system design
well um attackers can find flaws and
seams and we have to get away from that
idea of just adding more um even in the
the environment where we have the the
free software environment or some of the
new uh popular programming methodologies
the agile programming none of those are
really oriented towards removing old
code
they're they're more towards adding new
features and all of that just leads to
Greater complexity uh at at the time of
the of the wear report and for 20 years
after any of us graduating with with an
advanced degree in Computing and some
who just on their own uh we could teach
someone
else everything from the bare circuitry
up to the human computer interface and
how it all worked and how it all fit
together uh I would contend there's no
person alive who can do that anymore
because the systems have gotten so
complex and that means that no one
really understands how the whole system
works and where the problems are so
that's another aspect of the the
misconception is the idea that adding
more makes things better or that
patching is somehow security those are
real
enemies of security because they add to
complexity because what these languages
are doing is they're allowing you to
express a problem and a solution to the
problem that you have in terms of a
computer binary now for our second
counter let's record whatever the value
of the tape head is which is either
going to be zero and one but we can use